[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 92 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very excited
because after this we're
going to have lunch.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, me too.
So hungry right now.
Also excited because
we're going to be
talking to Michael Will,
who works at a company
called Phoenix One.
And they do video games.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, one
of my favorite topics.
He has a really cool
story about basically how
he took his whole
infrastructure from on-prem, so
dedicated hardware, brought
it all over to the cloud.
Basically, it's an almost
direct lift and shift.
It's pretty cool.
He got some benefits and he
had to learn some lessons
and he's going to
share them all with us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Also, a very cool guy.
He's definitely a geek
into hardware stuff,
so interesting to hear
his experience of moving
from I know every single piece
of hardware running to I'm
running on the Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Very cool.
And then at the end,
we'll have a question
of the week, which
is about security,
security on App Engine.
How do you make sure that only
who you want to use a web page
are able to do use the web page?
MARK MANDEL: Oooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, magic.
Magic is one of the
options, indeed.
And before that, we have
the cool things of the week.
One of them-- and I'm going to
go with it because it involves
not only App Engine,
but also Go--
is "The New York
Times," they wrote--
so JP Robinson, which
is a principal software
engineer at "The New York
Times," also a user of Go
and lover of cats wrote--
MARK MANDEL: That's
the important bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's his bio.
Wrote a very cool
blog post explaining
how "The New York Times"
migrated their crossword page
from--
I think they were using
a lamp-like architecture,
they say.
I don't know exactly
what they mean by that.
But they migrated
the whole thing
to App Engine running in Go.
And they explain how
happy they are about it.
It's very cool
because they actually
give a decent amount
of technical detail.
It's not only about
like, oh, we moved.
They also talk about how they
do monitoring and alerting.
How they use Pub/Sub
in order to do
push stuff or subscriptions
and things like this.
It's very interesting.
A lot of detail.
Check it out.
I think it's definitely
worth reading.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
They do some interesting stuff
around auto scaling, which
I thought was interesting.
But I think the
real takeaway here
was they managed to cut their
infrastructure costs in half--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --doing
this, so I thought
that was pretty impressive.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's a line basically saying
that their previous setup
in a Cloud provider competitor
was not elastic enough,
and that App Engine actually
fixed this because it's
able to scale up and down--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --super
fast and super easily.
So definitely check it out.
And if you have
some similar case,
like you have huge peaks
of traffic followed
by no one using your
app, it's definitely
worth to have a look at how App
Engine handles auto scaling.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So the second cool thing of the
week I'm kind of excited by--
it's probably a bit nerdy
but it's kind of cool.
We just announced--
now it is alpha,
so you need to get
whitelisted for it.
I'll say that up front.
But we just announced Network
Service Tiers, which I think
is super, super cool.
So one of the things
with Google Cloud
is we run our own
network, right?
It's the same network that
we run for Gmail and Maps
and for everything, right?
This is super fast and super
great except for the fact
it is kind of expensive.
Because we run all our
own hardware and we
do a lot of cool stuff for you.
Sometimes, though, you don't
want that super fast network.
You want something that's
maybe fairly similar to what
some other Cloud
providers have who
don't run their own networks.
And you want it at a
cheaper price point.
So now we have this thing called
network service tiers such
that you can have either the
standard, which is our premium
tier, where you have
great consistency,
great speed, everything else.
And then you have
the standard tier,
which uses much more
of the public internet
and much less of our
network, but that
does mean that you're
paying a whole lot less.
So maybe if you're moving
files, like large files,
from one place to another,
but you don't really
care how quickly they get there.
Like, if they get there in
the next day or so, it's fine,
so you don't have to pay
those huge egress costs
if you're moving them from,
say, a data center to us or back
again, all sorts of
things like that.
That means then, yeah, you don't
care as much about latency.
You don't care necessarily
about consistency
because it is over
the public internet.
You can save
yourself some money,
so it's actually
really, really cool.
I'm actually really
excited about this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I like that it's actually
configured, I see,
at a resource level.
So you can definitely--
you can basically
decide for every instance
or instance template or load
balancer, into what network tier
you're going to be using that.
So it's not like
all in, all out.
You could be like, well, you
know, for this specific thing,
I need to be really fast so
I'm going to go with premium.
With this old thing, it's a map
reduce that might take longer,
I don't care, then you can
go with basic for that.
MARK MANDEL: The right
network for the right job.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very, very cool.
And also, saving money, which--
I like that.
And then we have the last
cool thing of the week.
Actually, there were way too
many cool things of the week.
But the last one we
chose, it's about Titan,
which both of you and I
have one on our desks.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, we do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So Titan is a really
cool microchip
that Google designed
specifically
for Google
purpose-built servers.
So it's something that we
run internally at Google
and on Google Cloud, too.
And allows us to do really
cool security things
that we thought, this
kind of hardware,
you would not be able to do it.
So there's a new blog post
that covers Titan in depth.
It's definitely in depth.
It's a pretty long one.
But you will be able to
understand not only what
are the basics,
like what is Titan
and how it's built, from a
basic point of view, but also
what it empowers us to do
and what kind of security
we can manage.
For instance, make sure that
if someone accessed something,
we're able to see it, and the
login cannot be tampered with,
stuff like that.
Really, really powerful things
explained in a lot of detail.
And if you are interested
in knowing more,
but you're too lazy
to read, like me,
you can also listen
to the episode
that we did back in March,
with the final day at Cloud
Next, which was episode 67,
where we interviewed Cornelius
Willis, which is the head
marketing at Google Cloud
Platform.
And Neal Mueller, which
is a product marketing
lead also at Google Cloud.
And they told us a
little bit about it.
It is a very cool thing
and goes very well
on your earrings, apparently.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, I love this.
It just goes to
show, I think, what
levels we go to as a
company to ensure security,
that we write these
chips ourselves,
build these chips ourselves,
make these chips ourselves,
such that we can be like,
these machines are ours.
The software that's
running on them is ours.
Everything that's
happening on this machine
has not been tampered with
in any way, shape, or form.
And we make sure that we
own that from end to end.
And that's like,
yay, security, yay.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is pretty amazing, but
at the same time, incredibly
important to make sure that your
workloads are running where you
really think they are running.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right.
Well, why don't we go have
a chat with Michael Will,
talk to him about his
game "Guardian Kingdoms"?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: So it is an
absolute pleasure today
to join one of my friends on
stage from New York, Michael
Will, Director of Technical
Operations at Phoenix One
Games.
Michael, how are
you doing today?
MICHAEL WILL:
Excellent, how are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
very, very well.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
Coming to talk to
us about Phoenix One
Games, your newly released
game, "Guardian Kingdoms."
I don't know if we can still
count it as new anymore.
That you have a mobile, but
before we get stuck into that
and how you use
Google Cloud Platform,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what do you do
at Phoenix One Games?
MICHAEL WILL: Hi,
I'm Michael Will.
I work at Phoenix
One Games as Director
of Technical Operations.
So I take care of the back
end of the game, basically.
I have a systems engineering
background, hardware--
I used to make high-performance
compute cluster at Penguin
Computing before, before I
went into the gaming industry.
And so with that focus, I'm
also designing my back end
and we will talk
about the details
of what that means later.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So tell us a little bit
about "Guardian Kingdoms."
What it is-- what is it?
MICHAEL WILL:
"Guardian Kingdoms"
is a real-time
strategy game that's
similar to "Clash of
Clans," in the sense
that you build your own
kingdom and you defend it
against other people and you
build up resources and so on.
But what's unique about
this is that you actually
have massive, real-time gameplay
with three people on your side,
three people on the other side.
And all of them drop
hundreds of units,
so your battlefield is full
of thousands of units moving
and it's pretty exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So there's basically six
players for every game,
but every player has--
MICHAEL WILL: Up to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
up to six players.
MICHAEL WILL: So
the thing is you
are organized in
alliances, just like you
would be in those other games.
But the nice thing is
that if you get attacked,
they all get notifications
on their phone
and they can actually
help you and participate.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Fun.
MICHAEL WILL: Or they
can just observe.
So it's like, you might
have 10, 15 people observing
the game and two people on your
side that are supporting you.
And they can join at any moment.
So it really can turn also
the game around, which is fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So let's talk a little bit
about how it's implemented.
It's a mobile game.
What runs on the mobile,
what runs on the back end?
Tell us a little bit.
MICHAEL WILL: Right.
So it's basically a
typical client server
type multi-tier application.
So the phone, as your client,
it does all the graphics
and it connects through
HTTPS REST to a web farm,
if you want, that implements
the API for the game.
And so anything that your
phone client asks of the game,
the game first validates.
So if you say, I
want to spend 50 gold
on upgrading this tower,
then it will basically
verify that you actually have
that before it does that.
So the battle simulations are
actually done on battle servers
that are implemented in C++.
And we use some artificial
intelligence scripting,
using Lua technology in
there for best performance.
And then the back end servers
[INAUDIBLE] from the API,
basically, to the game.
That's implemented in PHP.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I think the
interesting story here
is that you used
to run, basically,
this whole thing on bare metal.
And you did that
for quite a while.
Can you tell us a bit about
what that experience was like
and what you did there?
MICHAEL WILL: Yeah.
It's more of a hardware systems
engineering approach, right?
So you basically design web
servers, database servers,
and so on.
And with the servers,
you basically
look at which ones are
most critical and those
who make us redundant as
possible inside of the server.
So you basically architect
for server resiliency.
And so for a
database server, that
means I want to have
redundant power supplies so
that if one of the power cables
gets disconnected by accident
or one of the power supplies
fails, the system keeps running
and it can be hot-swapped out.
And the same goes
for disk drive.
So there's hardware
rate, which means
you have a bunch of disks.
Data is redundantly
distributed amongst them.
And so if one of
the disks fails,
an operator can
replace the disk drive
without the system
shutting down.
And it can just keep
writing its data
and it will reshuffle the data
as a new disk is inserted.
So hardware systems
engineering focus here
is that you actually
look into the details as,
like, do I want two
rate controllers
for best performance?
Do I want to have multiple
volumes and stripe
across those ends?
So you can do a lot
of optimization there.
And you also want to
control the firmware
and be really, very specific
about what you end up
putting into production,
that you have tested
and you know it works.
And so that's the hardware
systems engineering
focus that you have, basically.
And what's different
now in the Cloud
is you don't have that access
anymore to the detail, which
at first, seems like a problem.
But it actually is a
blessing because it allows
you to change your approach.
So I'm no longer a
hardware system engineer.
But rather, I'm a
distributed systems engineer.
And so instead of looking at a
single server never going down,
what I do instead is I look at
the servers never going down
by having enough servers and
having failover and building
to my software stack.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Let's dig deeper into that.
So you had your hardware.
It was kind of working.
It seems to me like
it was working.
What were the reasons
why you actually ended up
transferring over to the cloud?
I mean, obviously,
you were talking
about moving to more
of a software focus,
but were there other
aspects to that, as well?
MICHAEL WILL: So
a typical problem
that a startup like
us faces is that we
need to match our costs with
revenue or potential revenue,
right?
So we don't want to
overspend, basically,
because every dollar
that we don't spend
on unnecessary stuff
idling around we
can put towards acquiring
more players that actually
bring revenue.
So what we found is
that with the hardware,
it's kind of hard to
scale up and down.
So we had a nice
contract that would
allow us to say, OK, we don't
need those servers anymore.
And then they say, OK,
by the end of the month,
you stop paying for it.
Which is OK, but it basically
makes you think like,
oh it's the 31st.
We really need to
cancel this server now,
otherwise we pay
another month for it.
And so the other thing is if you
want to scale up because you've
got more players and the
system starts slowing down
and you're like, oh, I
need 20 more web servers,
they can give them
to you in two days.
But then you are vetting
them for another week
and reject some, get
some replacements,
and get some miscommunication
keyed up and, by the end,
it's two weeks.
Especially if it's
database servers,
you will definitely
need two weeks
to put them into production.
And so that's
rather slow-moving.
And so the premise of
the cloud, of course,
is that you can spin up stuff
in minutes and shut it back down
and that you only pay
for it when you use it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Also, I'm wondering,
you give a little
bit of the reasoning
behind moving to the cloud,
but how easy or hard was it?
Did you need to
rewrite many things
or basically, all of the
things that you had already
just worked?
MICHAEL WILL: It's
basically super easy
because we were already a
Linux-focused, open source
architecting shop, right?
So everything we did was
[INAUDIBLE],, basically.
Originally, we did really
use Linux, MySQL, Memcache,
and that kind of stuff.
And then we replaced MySQL
and Memcache with Couchbase
at some point to
have less dependency
on individual
servers going down--
remember, the original problem.
And so--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MICHAEL WILL: --that
all translates very well
into running it on the Cloud
because it's also Linux
and I can use the same
services as before.
So one important piece for
PHP developers is knowing,
how does my code perform,
in general, right?
So if a request comes
in, I want to have
a feel for why a login
is slower or what
are the slowest requests
that I need to focus on?
And so we use a service
that's called New Relic that's
basically like PHP Xdebug, but
without the crazy tools that
take up all your
engineering time
to evaluate what you found.
And so what it allows you is
to see statistics in real time,
basically.
See, oh yeah, for
some reason, logins
got slower and purchases of this
one item have really slowed.
And then you see stack traces
of the actual execution
of the code.
You can see, oh, we did
1,000 gets on Couchbase.
I thought we were
just going to do 10.
Let me look at the
code and fix this.
So we can use the same servers
like we used to before.
So it's dropped in the
same kind of stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So which actual GCP products
are you using, then?
MICHAEL WILL: So
we use basically
Compute Engine because,
for me, as somebody
who used to be
obsessive about firmware
on individual components,
it's basically, OK, I
have to let go of this
micromanaging a little bit.
And the first step
is replicating
the same architecture
on the cloud
so I can basically
have a load balancer.
I have my web servers, I
have my battle servers,
I have Couchbase and
whatever services I use.
Like Vertica is another database
that we use for analytics.
And we use Reddit
for matchmaking
and that kind of stuff.
That all runs the same way.
And the way we deploy
this is with Chef,
and that used to be the
same on the hardware
as it is now, except for
it's much more flexible
and goes faster and I can do it
with less impact on the cost.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
now I'm wondering,
you were talking
about how passionate
you were about hardware.
Moving into the cloud, did
you use custom machines?
Because you know,
it was like you
can tune exactly how much
RAM, how many spews and stuff
like that you used?
Or what kind of instances
did you move to?
MICHAEL WILL: I basically
maximized memory
for the database
servers and computer
basically to not
be bottlenecked.
And basically, the approach
is get the maximum first
and then tune it on later so
you notice what you really need.
MARK MANDEL: I think when
we talked previously,
you got some nice notifications
from us saying that maybe you
want to lower some usage there.
MICHAEL WILL: Right.
So I mean, the tools
that Google built
are just great, especially
in comparison to other cloud
vendors.
I have to say, that's really
been one of the reasons
why we went with Google,
is how quickly we
were able to bring
up a prototype,
and then say, hey, that
prototype, we will actually
turn into production.
Can we do this
tomorrow kind of thing.
And so one of the tools
is the web interface,
where you can basically
customize your machines
and it even teaches you how
to use it in automated cases.
There's a little button
that you can click
and then you see
what the REST code
would have been to achieve
what you are trying to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's super useful.
MICHAEL WILL: So the
same web interface also
shows you which machines that
you are running underutilized
and it actually gives
you recommendations
on paring it down to save
money, which is kind of cool.
So it shows you, oh,
yeah, you have only
been using 20% of
RAM of this machine.
Why don't you use a custom
machine and you can save
$50 a month on this machine?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
You mentioned that, for
the database instances,
you were maximizing RAM.
What about storage?
MICHAEL WILL: Storage.
Well, you pay per
gigabyte, right?
So originally, I also maximized
that until I realized the cost
impact to its fullest.
I mean, we did back of the
end calculations originally,
but it really is a
different mix of costs
that you have to be
aware of, especially
if you plan to do
what we are doing,
which is have some of
the instances turned off
so you don't get billed
for the CPU time at all.
But you can bring
them up really fast
without having to reinstall
everything on them.
And the storage that's
attached, however,
is going to be built as if
it is running because it
is occupying the space.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MICHAEL WILL: Right?
So you pay for what
you're using, basically.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But were
you using, for the storage,
were you using persistent disks?
What kind of disks
were you using?
MICHAEL WILL: So Couchbase uses
network attached [INAUDIBLE]
on disk.
So SSDs for our lowest latency,
highest IOPS was the goal.
And then the user--
your Google servers are
called Google Storage in order
to do backups.
So instead of having a separate
file server like we used to do,
we now basically just drop
it onto Google Storage,
which is really easy to
use, also, with the tools
that you have.
It sets a web interface
that's a command line
interface that's really easy
to integrate into your scripts.
So I just run a few
lines of shell code
and basically, I can spool data
from one system to the other
with it.
So what I'm doing is
the battle servers,
they log out the actions that
happened and when people drop
[INAUDIBLE] and so on.
And all this data is basically
just a big large file.
And I just have a
Cron script running
that drops it into a
directory on Google Storage.
And then I have a
different system
that, again in the Cron
job, just takes everything
that it finds there
and then takes it apart
and inserts it into Vertica as
comma-separated value files,
which gives you the
highest throughput.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
you just you just
brought up Vertica,
which is, I know,
a big data processing tool.
MICHAEL WILL: Yeah
It's like BigQuery,
but it's for a smaller
capacity if you want.
It's basically a
relational database
that's column-oriented.
That means inserts
are really slow,
but selects are super fast.
So if I run a query
on a billion rows,
I can get a response in
under two seconds, sometimes
under one second.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And that's
used more for analytics
on what happened previously,
before, so it's not real time
or anything.
MICHAEL WILL: Right.
It's an offline thing.
So basically, the game
emits events like, oh,
Player X purchased this or did
that action or tried to cheat
or whatever we
detect in the game.
And it basically gets
collected and then
we run analytics on it.
We also use an external service
called Periscope for basically
graphing that kind of stuff.
So you can have your queries in
there and get nice dashboards.
And it basically talks directly
to our Vertica back end.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I have so many
questions right now.
MARK MANDEL: I have
lots of questions.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
first question that I have
is, OK, so you're using
SSDs to store the database,
but you're also storing
some of that information
into cloud storage.
Then you read from
cloud storage,
kind of like Map Reduce
style or whatever,
like a big batch process.
And then you store
that into Vertica.
MICHAEL WILL: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Is that correct?
MICHAEL WILL: That's
kind of how it is, yeah,
in terms of getting analytics
data into a queryable system.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
once it's in Vertica,
you're actually
starting again on SSDs,
so the access is really fast.
MICHAEL WILL: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Cool.
So my questions are--
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL WILL: And
then RAM, of course,
because the Vertica
servers have lots of RAM.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In order
to make it actually fast.
MICHAEL WILL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
my first question
is, when you're storing
on cloud storage,
then it means that basically
you read it only once,
and then you just
leave it there forever?
Are you using something
like Nearline or Coldline,
or have you considered
these things?
MICHAEL WILL: We have considered
it, but time is precious,
so what we do is
basically we just
have it on whatever the
default was at the time.
And then we will
tune that later.
The main cost, really, is in
the actual SSDs, the network
attached disk drives, more
than the Nearline storage,
if you want.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And then the second
question is, since you're
doing that offline
batching process,
how are you doing those?
Is that also machines
running on GCE?
MICHAEL WILL: Yep.
Everything there runs on GCE.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And whenever
you're doing something offline,
my question is always the same.
Are you using preemptible
machines or, again,
it's something that you
might consider later on?
MICHAEL WILL: Beats me.
I mean, I want the systems to
be as reliable as possible.
That's still the system
engineer talking, right?
So I see them migrate
every now and then.
And for a real-time game, that's
actually not really great.
But it works fairly
well, so it's OK.
And in particular,
what I've seen
is that you hot migrate the
image and within a second,
it can respond again,
or a few seconds.
And I think that
only works really
because the image doesn't
contain all the data,
but the network
attached disks can
be pointed to from the
new location easily.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Then what you're
doing-- that offline
batch actually
needs to be active all
of the time, right?
So it's not like an offline
thing that it runs every day.
It runs continuously--
MICHAEL WILL: It runs
continuously, yeah.
It's a constant feeding process.
It's just that it's decoupled
from the actual gameplay.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
That makes total sense.
MICHAEL WILL: Right.
MARK MANDEL: So actually
this is interesting, too.
From first glance, talking about
what we were talking about,
everything is sort of GCE.
You're running your own
sort of analytics pipeline.
Probably the only managed
service you're using
is Cloud Storage and
maybe some load balancing.
Was that a direct
choice to basically use
more of our infrastructure
as a service?
Or what was the
reasoning behind that?
MICHAEL WILL: Well,
the first approach
was, I have this hardware
architecture that
runs on bare metal.
And now, how do I make
this run on the cloud?
And then what services are
there that could make it easier?
So we were even
looking at replacing
Couchbase with data store.
But of course, our code
makes too many requests,
so that's not really feasible
at this point in time.
Because before, it was free and
now that would be transaction--
each transaction
costing a little bit.
And so we [INAUDIBLE].
We also looked a
lot into BigQuery,
because Vertica
machines eventually
will run out of space.
And that's the promise
of higher performance
by having more hardware
and resources front ended
from the Google side.
And so that didn't pan
out in the first iteration
so we didn't use that.
But we needed to replace the
file server with [? eval ?]
file server.
But then we saw that
it's much easier
to use with Google Storage and
it's also kind of unbounded.
I can just flow edit.
It never says, oh, disk
four, unlike the file server
that needs babysitting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
During the migration,
did you just move the whole
thing all of a sudden?
Like, you just got
the whole system
stopped from your on-prem
and moved it to the Cloud?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL WILL: We were
actually in development
when we made a decision
on where to run.
So we had previous games that
were running on bare metal
and that still are, that
we have left behind when
we moved companies around.
And those are
running great there,
but I don't have to worry
about those anymore.
And so the new
approach was, OK, we
could do it the
old fashioned way
or we can do it the new way.
And what really
brings us the value
besides the nice tools
is that we can actually
do a lot more load testing and
development, where you can just
put together a copy
of the live system
or even a bigger system
than the live system
and run it completely
independent of the live system.
And load test it
for a few hours--
30, 40 or so hours--
and then you shut them back
down and you don't pay for them
anymore after that.
You can just delete
them and they're gone.
Whereas, in the
previous approach,
we would have to have some
dedicated test hardware
and would always have to
extrapolate what it probably
would be like in the
bigger version and so on.
So it kind of opens
up possibilities that
just were not there before.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: When
you're doing these tests,
how do you measure
the performance?
Are you using New Relic
for this and tracking--
MICHAEL WILL: New Relic
is one part of it.
But New Relic is looking
at individual transactions.
But what I'm looking for
is volume and throughput.
And so one open source tool
that's really useful for that
is JMeter.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MICHAEL WILL: It's
written in Java
and it has a nice
Java UI for basically
making test plans and so on.
And you run the system
with just one web server,
print out all the
queries that come--
all the posts that go through it
when you test with your phone.
And you basically see, OK,
when my phone installs,
these are the
steps it will take.
And then you can convert
those into, basically,
a JMeter test blend that can
do 1,000 of them in parallel.
And then you run some of
them on a few servers,
and then you get basically
4,000 requests coming in,
and you run it over
and over again.
MARK MANDEL: So is that just
HTTP requests or is that also
stress-testing your battle
servers, which are in C++?
MICHAEL WILL: It's all implied.
So the activity that you do is
just like the phones would do.
So it has consequences.
It's the same thing, basically.
It starts the battles.
It doesn't do the
randomized stuff
that real players would
do and there won't
be the same kind of delays.
But in order to get a worst
case scenario done, if I really
have $1 million [INAUDIBLE] a
day of people that really play
a lot, basically, then I can
see, how many servers do I
need for that?
And will it go down
or will it survive?
And so I'm looking at overall
throughput of installs.
And then I identify weak
points and I see, oh, yeah, I
needs more of my battle
servers than I thought.
Or I need to look at some of the
requests slowing down suddenly
because they are focused too
much on [? Reddits ?] and it's
overloaded, stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I wonder, other than
for the flexibility
of being able to
scale up and down
and add systems for
testing and QA and stuff
like that, what are other
benefits that you've seen,
or even what are the
problems that you've seen,
by migrating to the cloud?
MICHAEL WILL: Challenges
of migrating to the cloud,
of course, at first
is psychological.
Like there's this, oh--
MARK MANDEL: Your dear machines.
MICHAEL WILL: --is this
going to go away overnight?
And then what do I do?
So of course, we have backups
that are basically proven.
And I prove it to myself
every now and then
that I can build a new
system with the backup data
and it actually still works,
so that's a good thing.
That again, is something that
the cloud really supports.
The other challenge
that we found
was I was kind of
optimizing on hardware
and I was thinking I'd
do the same optimizations
on the cloud, but sometimes
simpler is just better.
So for the couch base
server, for example,
I was used to having two rate
controllers, four volumes that
are giving me maximum
IOPS, basically,
if I stripe across them.
And so I tried a similar
approach on the cloud.
And, in theory, that should
really work, but in reality,
it was actually better to
just use a single volume
that is then larger
and that is being
handled by Google on the back
end in order to maximize IOPS.
And so one of the lessons
learned is basically,
don't try so hard to do
the same optimizations
because they might actually
be in the way of success.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Go for the simple thing and
then, as you were saying,
test it and find how to
make it faster later.
That's cool.
MICHAEL WILL:
Another one is don't
try to use all the
services up front.
Like I said, we
were learning a lot
and spending a lot of time
on which services to use
and the approach to first
shift it into the cloud
and then disassemble it
later and look at, well,
if I take this
apart, can I actually
use some of the services?
Initially, I was really
thinking about a file server.
That one I could
rule out quickly.
But the Couchbase, that
will take us a while
to re-architect so
that we don't have
so many transactional
costs, for example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I wonder, you've
migrated up to a pretty
cloud-oriented point.
You have all of
these servers running
on the cloud and everything.
Are you planning on feature
migrations to other services?
What is the future roadmap?
MICHAEL WILL: Well, the future
is always wide open, right?
So we are fast-moving,
in terms of the features
that we're using.
I was looking just recently
at the translation API.
So I was thinking
like, oh, we have
all these international
chats going.
There are chat rooms in
Italian, some in Chinese,
some in Arabic.
Wouldn't it be nice if you
could look at, basically,
what they are saying,
besides having
to have language domain
experts in the company that
can tell me?
And so I was looking at that.
So that's one interesting thing.
And then, of
course, we're always
curious in learning more
about machine learning.
And every day, you come up with
new services and new stuff.
So that's what we
like about Google,
in general, is you guys are
fast-moving, just like we are,
and very innovative
and cutting edge.
And so new options
always come up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I guess we're
running out of time, according
to Mark's hand gestures.
So is there anything
else that you'd
like to mention that
we might have missed?
MICHAEL WILL: Well,
an anecdote would be--
and I hinted to that earlier--
the tools that we use to
basically prove to ourselves
that this is easy
to use and it was
much easier than other cloud
providers led to the situation
that we basically had a system
that was meant as a prototype,
but then was going to
be put into production.
And we were like, hey,
can you do this tomorrow?
And then, they're like, well,
you have infinite resources,
but you have to
negotiate a quota first.
And quota's basically your
framework for, how much will
you potentially use?
And it's kind of
reserved resources
so that they don't
run out of resources
just when you need them.
And so I think engaging early
to increase the quota when
you want to go live,
that's an important thing.
And yeah, that was maybe--
one take-away is it's so
easy that you could just move
right into production quickly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Are you working
with customer engineers, sales
engineers, or any
kind of those people
in order to do those quotas,
or is it completely automated?
MICHAEL WILL: Well, it's
somewhat bureaucratic.
There's a form and you fill it
out and then you talk about it.
But you have very
strong technical people,
and also a really
good sales guy that I
work with who understands
the technology just as
good as I do.
And so it was really easy
to talk with him about, OK,
this is important to
us and that one isn't.
And then he made it
happen on the back end
and pushed it forward.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I guess
that ties pretty well
to all of our other episodes
on customer engineers and sales
engineers and customer
reliability engineers and all
that stuff.
MICHAEL WILL: Lots of resources.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MICHAEL WILL: That's
generally what I like.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And also, make sure we
get all the plugs in.
You've got-- the app is out.
So "Guardian Kingdoms" is out on
iOS and Android is coming soon?
MICHAEL WILL: Yes.
Definitely by the
end of the year,
you will see an Android version.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Wonderful.
We'll have links in the
show notes to the website,
so everyone who wants to go
play the game can find it.
MICHAEL WILL: All right.
Play "Guardian Kingdoms."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Will, thank you so much
for spending time with us
and answering all our
ridiculous questions,
or maybe not so ridiculous.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
MICHAEL WILL: Yeah, same here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks
so much to Michael Will
to spend some time
today and tell us
a little bit about the whole
experience of migrating
something as hard to migrate--
a game environment-- from
very well-known hardware
to the cloud, and how everything
worked out really well.
Very, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Yeah, thanks again to Michael.
It was a really good
story and I think
he had a really good
take on the right steps
to take when migrating and when
to make those trade-offs about,
do I use the new things?
Do I just continue
with what I know,
and then just make small
steps, which they did.
I thought that was a really,
really interesting take.
Why don't we move on to
our question of the week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And so the question
is a pretty general one,
but that has many answers,
and has a new one since
not that long ago.
So the question is, OK, how
do I secure an App Engine
application?
And by securing it, I
mean that only the people
I want to access the web page
will be able to access it.
That is the only one that
we care about right now.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There is one, which
is the typical one that I've
been using forever, which
is basically on your
[INAUDIBLE],, you can say,
login required, or even login
admin, for a specific endpoint.
So you can say, well,
this web page here, you
need to be logged
in to access it.
Now, if someone tries to access
it and they're not logged in,
what happens is that the App
Engine framework will actually
re-direct that to
a login page that
only works for Google
accounts, and then you
need to log in in there.
And by Google accounts,
I also mean Google Apps.
So if you have at
GCPpodcast.com,
for instance, is one of them.
You will log in and then go
back to the same web page.
And this time, you will be
authenticated so it will work.
Similarly, you can also
say that login is not
required, but admin.
And when you do this, not only
you need to be authenticated,
but you need to be also an
owner of the project where
that App Engine is hosted.
So for instance,
let's say that we
added some kind of
authentication for GCP Podcast.
Everybody could authenticate
to those, but only Mark
and I would be able to use those
that are marked as login admin.
These are also very
useful for when you're
doing things like Cron jobs.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cron jobs--
this is one of the things
that you really don't want
anyone to be able to hit.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because, in
general, they're expensive.
You don't want
someone to go and hit
like that once a second
for the rest of the day.
MARK MANDEL: And
obscurity is not security.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is not.
It can help a little
bit, but someone
will find it at some point.
So yeah, it is important
to be able to do required,
admin, stuff like that.
So that is one of the options.
MARK MANDEL: And it's
worth noting that that only
works with Google accounts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
It only works with
Google accounts.
A Google Apps account.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So second way--
I love what you've written here.
You do you.
I love that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Everything goes.
You do you.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
So basically, build your own
authentication into your app.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe use
something like data store
for the back end storage, build
your own OAuth provider, hook
into existing OAuth providers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
stole your passport
without even encrypting them,
[INAUDIBLE] your [? salt. ?]
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Whatever level
that you are comfortable with.
Please don't do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do not do that.
MARK MANDEL: Do not do that.
So more work,
obviously, but that
enables you full
control over everything
from how you want
people to authenticate
and what you want to build into.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And also
following this same idea
of using OAuth 2, you
do not need to implement
the whole thing by yourself.
O Auth 2 is kind of
hard to implement.
It's never fun.
But there's providers that
allow you to do these basically
with zero effort.
One of them-- my favorite
one-- is Firebase auth.
Firebase authentication
will allow
you to provide a very simple
way of doing authentication
using OAuth 2.
And not only with
Google accounts,
but also Facebook, Twitter--
anything They even
support GitHub and stuff.
They support a bunch of them.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And you don't need
to do anything on your site.
Everything you do is
you receive a token
and then you use a
library to try to identify
what user is behind that token.
Super cool.
In a very similar way, Auth Zero
does something quite similar.
So check those out if
what you want to do
is authentication with many
different kinds of accounts
and you don't really want to
tie yourself to one provider.
MARK MANDEL: So we also
have this neat thing called
the Identity Aware Proxy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Also known as
Beyond [? Corps. ?]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
mostly internally.
But yeah, yeah, yeah.
So Identity Aware Proxy
is actually kind of cool,
in that it is a layer that
sits in front of App Engine,
as well as some other products,
if you really want to,
that enables you to basically
control complete access based
on who these people are.
So you can set up roles
and responsibilities.
Again, this is linked to Google
accounts, so keep that in mind.
That if somebody comes in who's
not meant to access this app,
then they don't even
get to hit that URL.
That never happens.
And you can set up
a bunch of rules.
This is nice because not only
can you apply it in one place,
you could then apply
it in multiple places
around your organization
from multiple apps,
as well, which is quite nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is really cool.
Let's imagine that
you have a company
and that company has four or
five different applications
and you want to use the same
authentication schema for all
of them, which makes sense.
This is probably the
easiest way to do it.
Rather than having
authentication
in every single one of
those apps, what you do
is you protect those apps with
the Cloud Identity Aware proxy,
or actually you could do both.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You could do both.
The nice thing, as well,
is the Identity Aware Proxy
will pass through
who the user is.
So it not only provides access
protection, but also has,
basically, user login.
You get that information
as it comes through.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
one of the cool things
is that this is
something that will
stop a request from
getting to your application
in the first place, unless
it's been authenticated.
So it's pretty good.
App Engine, for instance,
if you keep on hitting it,
you will have an
instance running.
It might even scale up if
you got a lot of traffic.
If that traffic is
not authenticated,
that traffic will never hit
your instance, so you're good.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's pretty cool.
Now, if I want to lock it
down to just a section of IPs?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
So that's what we
call a firewall,
and that's the new thing.
We have an App Engine
firewall and it is as simple
as it sounds.
It is a firewall
where you can say,
only requests coming from
this specific IP or this range
of IPs is able to hit my app.
If they're not coming
in from those IPs,
they will be dropped.
So your application will not
receive any of that traffic.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
I think if I wanted
to use these in combo,
I would probably do something
like Cloud Identity Aware Proxy
plus an App Engine firewall.
So if I've got, say,
a corporate network,
I know what my IP range
is, so I know, OK,
this can only come from
within these IP ranges.
And then IAP on top of that
so that I have both layers.
Maybe if I accidentally
misconfigure IAP,
I still have the
added protection
of the IP range and vice versa.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I don't know.
I think that Cloud Identity
Aware Proxy is secure enough.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But Cloud Identity
Aware Proxy, it
makes it so you need
to authenticate.
So probably what I would do
is use Cloud Identity Aware
Proxy for all the things
where users are using it.
But then use App Engine
firewall for when
you have a different
system that is hitting you.
And you know what IP
you're using, so it's like,
only that can--
kind of like a remote Cron
job or something that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you
could do that, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
could help, I think.
But yeah.
MARK MANDEL: There's
probably lots
of layers you could put
this stuff together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, maybe we
should do an episode on this.
MARK MANDEL: It would be cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because that
was a lot of information.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Awesome.
All right.
So you have lots of
fun tools to play with.
But before we wrap up today,
Francesc, what are you up to?
What are you doing?
Where are you going?
What's happening?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
going to the land
of kangaroos and koalas.
I'm going to Australia
for the Cloud Summit
in Sydney, which will take place
Wednesday, 13 of September.
After that, I'll
be back for a week
and then I'll go
to Next in Chicago,
where I will be speaking
about TensorFlow.
I'm very excited.
I'm doing a lot of
machine learning lately.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
You look like you're
enjoying that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
I'm going to be speaking about
TensorFlow and how to use it.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
then, in October, I'll
be to Velocity in London
to speak about performance
profiling in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: When this
episode comes out,
I'll be in the second
day of Pax Dev,
and then I'll be attending
Pax West, playing
all the games with
all my friends,
which I'm super excited about.
Then after that, I have a Game
Con Las Vegas in September,
as well as Austin game
conference, and then attending
Strange Loop.
And strangely enough, as well--
no pun intended,
actually, there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's great.
So in October, I will be
heading to Australia, as well.
I will be speaking at Dev Fest
Melbourne, which is in October.
The-- what do I have?--
21st of October.
But then I'll be doing
all the stuff at Melbourne
International Games Week.
So I'm speaking at GCAP--
Game Connect Asia Pacific.
I'm hoping to speak
at Pax Australia.
We shall see.
But at the very
least, I'll be there,
and I'll be at Unite
Melbourne, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So if anyone wants
to say hello, drop me a line.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've
got to congratulate you
on your very native
pronunciation of Melbourne.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I did live
there for most of my life.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
sounds very, very local.
I like it.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So Francesc, thank you so
much for joining me yet again
for another episode
of the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]